Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky BBQ glaze and topped with a creamy BBQ sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In April 1977, Bev Roberts was anxiously awaiting the Easter long weekend. Her younger brother, Russell Martin, had abruptly left town earlier that year, leaving behind his wife and four young children. It wasn't out of character for Russell to take off from time to time, but he always kept in touch. This time, no one had heard from him. Russell was born and raised in the small, regional town of Stahl in Victoria's West. Stahl meant a lot to the 31 year old. The heritage Gold Rush era township prospered during the 1850s mining boom, attracting a population of more than 30,000 people. When the yields were no longer commercially viable by the mid 1920s, the population began to dwindle. Those who remained were small town families, farmers and retirees. Those who preferred a quiet way of life among a close-knit community. By the 1970s, the population of Stahl was around 6000 residents, many of whom struggled to find steady employment. Most of the manufacturing industries had closed and the railway depot had been relocated, leaving few job opportunities. The town relied heavily on tourism and hospitality, an industry serviced by the town's proximity to the sprawling, forest-covered mountain ranges of the Grampians National Park.
你尝试过双重烧烤的风味吗？想象一下。新鲜烹制的酥脆调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉面，再淋上浓郁的烧烤酱。想象不出来？现在你就可以去Tim's尝尝了。限时推出我们的全新烧烤脆鸡丰富碗和卷饼。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您手机应用上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。1977年4月，贝芙·罗伯茨（Bev Roberts）正焦急地期盼着复活节长周末的到来。她的弟弟拉塞尔·马丁（Russell Martin）今年早些时候突然离开小镇，留下了他的妻子和四个年幼的孩子。拉塞尔偶尔离开一段时间并不算反常，但他总是与外界保持联系。这一次，谁也没有他的消息。拉塞尔在维多利亚州西部小镇斯塔勒（Stahl）出生并长大。斯塔勒对这个31岁的年轻人有着特殊的意义。这座历史悠久的淘金热时期城镇在1850年代的采矿热潮中繁荣起来，吸引了超过3万人口。到了1920年代中期，当产量不再具有商业价值时，人口开始减少。留下来的人都是小镇家庭、农民和退休人员。他们是那些在紧密团结的社区中偏爱安静生活方式的人。到了1970年代0，斯塔勒的人口约为6000名居民，其中许多人难以找到稳定的工作。大多数制造业工厂已经关闭，铁路仓库也已搬迁，几乎没有留下什么就业机会。小镇严重依赖旅游业和酒店业，这个行业得益于小镇靠近格兰屏国家公园（Grampians National Park）连绵起伏、森林密布的山脉的地理位置。
It was the landscape and lifestyle Stahl offered that kept Russell Martin from leaving town for good. His social life revolved around the local pubs and footy club, where he was known by his mates as Stabba, and would delight crowds with his piano accordion. No matter where he went or why, Russell's journey always led him back home. Bev was hoping Russell would return for the biggest event on the town's calendar, the Stahl Gift. Occurring over the Easter long weekend, the Stahl Gift is the oldest and richest short-distance foot race in Australia. It draws in large crowds of participants, supporters and punters from across the country and further afield. Russell Martin always looked forward to the gift. Bev knew that if her brother didn't turn up to place a bet on the races, something was terribly wrong. The 1977 Stahl Gift came and went with no sign of Russell Martin. On May 3, Bev and her mother Ellen visited the local police station to file a missing persons report. It had been three and a half months since Russell left town unexpectedly without offering a good buy. Bev and Ellen knew better than most that Russell was not a perfect person. He had his vices, mainly drinking and gambling, and was hot-headed and prone to violence. But he loved his children.
正是斯塔勒提供的风景和生活方式，让拉塞尔·马丁没有彻底离开小镇。他的社交生活围绕着当地的酒吧和澳式足球俱乐部展开，他在那里被朋友们称为“斯塔巴”（Stabba），并常常用钢琴手风琴为观众带来欢乐。无论他去哪里，出于什么原因，拉塞尔的旅程总是引导他回到家中。贝芙希望拉塞尔能回来参加小镇日历上最大的活动——斯塔勒赛跑（Stahl Gift）。斯塔勒赛跑在复活节长周末举行，是澳大利亚历史最悠久、奖金最丰厚的短跑比赛。它吸引了来自全国各地及更远地区的广大参赛者、支持者和赌徒。拉塞尔·马丁总是期盼着这项赛事的到来。贝芙知道，如果她的弟弟没有出现去为比赛下注，那就一定是出了大问题。1977年的斯塔勒赛跑就这样过去了，没有一丝拉塞尔·马丁的踪迹。5月3日，贝芙和她的母亲埃伦（Ellen）前往当地警察局报案失踪。距离拉塞尔不告而别、离开小镇已经过去了三个半月。贝芙和埃伦比大多数人都清楚，拉塞尔并不是一个完美的人。他有自己的恶习，主要是酗酒和赌博，而且脾气火爆，容易使用暴力。但他深爱着自己的孩子们。
Whenever he was out of town, Russell would at the very least keep in touch with his kids. Yet they hadn't heard from him. Knowing her son's temperament, Ellen feared that Russell would cause harm if he returned to town. He would be incensed to find out that his wife, Helen, had moved another man into their marital home. Russell and Helen's relationship dated back to when they were teenagers. Russell's siblings disapproved of the pairing from the outset. Helen Wilcock had a reputation as a wild child, and Russell was possessive and prone to jealousy. They advised against the couple marrying, but Russell and Helen went ahead with the ceremony. In 1964, they became Mr and Mrs Martin. Both were 19 years old. They had four children and eventually settled into a three bedroom weatherboard house on Ligar Street, not far from the main street of store. Their daughters, Lee and Kelly, shared one room. Their sons, Stephen and Paul, shared the second. Russell and Helen had the third. It wasn't an idyllic marriage. Russell and Helen were products of disadvantaged backgrounds, and it influenced their treatment of one another.
每当他外出不在镇上时，拉塞尔至少会与他的孩子们保持联系。然而他们却没有他的消息。了解儿子脾气的埃伦担心，如果拉塞尔回到镇上会惹出乱子。当他发现妻子海伦（Helen）已经让另一个男人搬进他们的婚姻住宅时，他一定会怒不可遏。拉塞尔和海伦的关系可以追溯到他们的青少年时期。拉塞尔的兄弟姐妹从一开始就不赞成这段感情。海伦·威尔考克（Helen Wilcock）素有野孩子之称，而拉塞尔则占有欲强且容易嫉妒。他们曾劝阻两人结婚，但拉塞尔和海伦还是举行了婚礼。1964年，他们成为了马丁先生和夫人。两人当时都是19号岁。他们育有四个孩子，最终在离斯塔勒主街不远的利加街（Ligar Street）定居在一栋三居室的木板房里。他们的女儿莉伊（Lee）和凯利（Kelly）共用一间卧室。他们的儿子斯蒂芬（Stephen）和保罗（Paul）共用第二间。拉塞尔和海伦则住第三间。这并不是一段田园诗般的婚姻。拉塞尔和海伦都出身于弱势背景，这影响了他们彼此对待对方的方式。
Russell was the sixth of seven children, born on July 10, 1945. His parents, Michael and Ellen, were problem drinkers. They would often stay out all night until they'd spent all their money or were escorted home by police. Some of their drinking binges lasted weeks. They fought loudly and frequently over their many problems, including Ellen's flagrant infidelity. Throughout his childhood, Russell was at the centre of a rumour regarding the identity of his biological father. He was also bullied for being the child of the town drunks, as well as for his poor hygiene and academic struggles. The Martin children were severely neglected by their parents. Child protection officers visited the household, but the children would hide in the nearby forest to avoid them. Sometimes they'd sleep out there for days at a time and arrive at school dirty and unkempt. Russell was teased for having burrs stuck in his knotty hair. He would try to remove them himself, but the results were disastrous and only caused more ridicule.
拉塞尔是七个孩子中的老六，出生于1945年7月10日。他的父母迈克尔（Michael）和埃伦都是问题饮酒者。他们经常在外面待上一整夜，直到花光所有的钱，或者被警察护送回家。他们的一些酗酒狂欢持续数周之久。他们为许多问题大声且频繁地争吵，包括埃伦公然的不忠。在整个童年时期，拉塞尔一直是关于他亲生父亲身份谣言的中心。他还因为是镇上酒鬼的孩子、个人卫生差以及学业困难而受到欺凌。马丁家的孩子们受到了父母的严重忽视。儿童保护官员曾造访这户人家，但孩子们会躲在附近的森林里以避开他们。有时他们会在那里露宿数日，到达学校时又脏又邋遢。拉塞尔因为头发纠结、缠着芒刺而遭到嘲笑。他曾试图自己拔掉它们，但结果却糟透了，反而招致了更多的嘲笑。
Russell learned to retaliate with his fists and became known as a fierce fighter who wasn't afraid of anyone. Helen had experienced her husband's violence firsthand. Police officers attended domestic disputes at the couple's house, sometimes as often as once a month, but charges were rarely laid. Helen felt sorry for Russell. She believed he only acted the way he did because of his upbringing, which had caused him to hate women. When reporting her son missing, Helen Martin expressed concern for Helen in particular. She feared that Russell would harm his wife if he found out she had moved on with another man. Helen said that the only way Helen would have a new boyfriend was if she knew for sure that Russell was never coming back. Russell's sister Bev felt Helen had been behaving suspiciously since January. For new years, Russell and Helen took their children on a lakeside camping trip 160km west of store. It was the couple's first holiday together in their 13-year relationship. Bev tagged along for the first few days of the trip.
拉塞尔学会了用拳头进行反击，并以一个谁也不怕的凶猛斗士而闻名。海伦曾亲身体验过丈夫的暴力。警察曾多次前往这对夫妇的房子处理家庭纠纷，有时甚至一个月一次，但很少提起指控。海伦为拉塞尔感到难过。她认为他之所以会有这样的行为，完全是因为他的成长经历，这导致了他对女性的仇恨。海伦·马丁在报案儿子失踪时，特别对海伦表达了担忧。她担心如果拉塞尔发现妻子已经和另一个男人在一起了，会对她不利。海伦说，海伦能交新男友的唯一可能，就是她确信拉塞尔永远不会回来了。拉塞尔的姐姐贝芙觉得海伦自1月以来表现得十分可疑。新年期间，拉塞尔和海伦带着他们的孩子去了一次位于斯塔勒以西160公里的湖畔露营旅行。这是这对夫妇在13年感情中第一次一起度假。贝芙在旅行的前几天也跟着一起去了。
On several occasions, Helen left the campsite without good explanation. The mountains returned to stall around to January 13, and Russell continued his woodcutting business. He spent the next few days chopping up some wood so he could sell it. Then, on Tuesday, January 25, Helen visited Bev. She asked if Bev could deliver the wood to one of Russell's customers. It was a strange request. Bev wondered why her brother had gone to the effort to prepare the wood, only to not follow through with its sale. According to Helen, Russell had spent Tuesday, January 18 in bed. At 11.10pm, he asked her for the time and date.
海伦有好几次在没有合理解释的情况下离开露营地。山脉于1月13日左右返回斯塔勒，拉塞尔则继续他的伐木生意。他在接下来的几天里劈了一些木柴以便出售。接着，在1月25日星期二，海伦拜访了贝芙。她问贝芙是否能把木柴送到拉塞尔的一位客户那里。这是一个奇怪的请求。贝芙感到纳尔闷，为什么她的弟弟费了力气准备好木柴，却又不去完成这笔交易。据海伦所说，拉塞尔在1月18日星期二一整天都躺在床上。晚上11点10分，他向她询问时间和日期。
When Helen answered, he got up and said he had to go out for a minute. He returned at 1.20am to pick up some clothing, his toothbrush and toothpaste. He placed $100 cash on the bench along with the new watch that Helen had given him for Christmas. He told her to sell it and anything else she needed. Russell then apparently said, I can never come back to stall again. I'm sorry. I'm glad we had the holiday. He told Helen to prepare herself for a couple of shocks and then walked out the front door. Helen ran to the window and saw the back end of what looked like a white wagon or panel van.
当海伦回答后，他起身说他得出去一会。他在凌晨1点20分回来取了一些衣服、牙刷和牙膏。他在长凳上放了100美元现金，还有海伦圣诞节送给他的新手表。他让她把手表和她需要的任何其他东西卖掉。拉塞尔随后显然说道：“我再也不能回斯塔勒了。对不起。我很高兴我们度过了这个假期。”他告诉海伦做好面对几次打击的准备，然后走出了前门。海伦跑到窗前，看到了一辆看起来像白色旅行车或厢式货车的车尾。
Russell got into the passenger seat and the car took off. Helen begged Bev not to tell anybody. She said it was likely that Russell had just been drunk and would be back soon. She wanted to avoid the humiliation of people knowing he had left her again. Russell had previously had an affair that resulted in a child. During that time, he periodically went back and forth between both women until his lover moved away. Bev knew Russell could take off for several days or weeks at a time, so Helen's story sounded plausible enough. She did think it was strange that he left while nursing a broken ankle.
拉塞尔坐上了副驾驶座，汽车随之驶离。海伦恳求贝芙不要告诉任何人。她说拉塞尔可能只是喝醉了，很快就会回来。她想避免那种人们知道他又抛弃自己的屈辱感。拉塞尔以前有过一段导致生下一个孩子的婚外情。在那期间，他在两个女人之间反复摇摆，直到他的情人搬走。贝芙深知拉塞尔可以一连离家几天甚至几周，因此海伦的说法听起来相当合情合理。她确实觉得奇怪的是，他竟然在脚踝骨折的情况下离开。
In fact, she was certain he was still relying on crutches to get around. She couldn't imagine why or how he would go travelling in such a condition. Nevertheless, she figured he would be back soon as he couldn't stand to be away from his children for long. A few days later, Bev and Helen spoke again. On this occasion, Helen said she had been mistaken about the date that Russell left. It had been the previous Thursday, not the Tuesday. She then broke down in tears, telling Bev that some money had gone missing from the Glenorchy Football Club and she believed Russell had taken it. He had played for the club before it folded due to poor performance and low player numbers.
事实上，她确信他当时出行仍然依靠拐杖。她无法想象他在那种情况下怎么会或为什么要出门旅行。不过，她琢磨着他很快就会回来，因为他无法忍受长时间离开自己的孩子们。几天后，贝芙和海伦再次交谈。这一次，海伦说她记错了拉塞尔离开的日期。那是前一个星期四，而不是星期二。接着她崩溃大哭，告诉贝芙格伦奥奇足球俱乐部（Glenorchy Football Club）丢失了一笔钱，她认为这笔钱是拉塞尔拿的。他曾为该俱乐部效力，后来该俱乐部因表现不佳和球员人数不足而解散。
When the club's accounts were finalised, only a small amount of money remained in the Treasury. It was obvious that someone appropriated what little funds had been in there. Helen Martin immediately fell under suspicion. She was the club's secretary and treasurer and was responsible for taking the money to be banked each week. Meetings were held to determine what happened to the missing money, but each time Helen provided an excuse as to why she couldn't attend. Helen claimed it was Russell who took the club's money. She said he used it to gamble and promised to return it from his winnings or the following week's earnings. Helen always gave her husband the money to avoid conflict and because he would take it anyway.
当俱乐部的账目最终结清时，国库里只剩下少量资金。很显然，有人侵占了那里仅存的资金。海伦·马丁立刻成了怀疑对象。她是俱乐部的秘首兼财务，负责每周将钱带去银行存起来。人们举行会议来查明丢失的资金去向，但每一次海伦都借故无法出席。海伦声称是拉塞尔拿了俱乐部的钱。她说他用这笔钱去赌博，并承诺用他的赢彩或接下来一周的收入来归还。海伦总是把钱给她丈夫以避免冲突，而且因为无论如何他都会抢走。
In the end, he borrowed more than he repaid. By season's end, there was almost no money in the club's bank account. Following this revelation, Bev offered to pay her brother's debt to avoid community backlash. She gave Helen $1,000 to pay a grocer, a baker and an electrical retailer that provided a TV for a club raffle. The bill came to $924. Helen kept the remainder for incidentals, promising to pay it back at a later date. A little while later, Bev bumped into Helen at the local milk bar. Helen asked if she had heard any talk around town about Russell.
最后，他借的钱比还的还要多。到了赛季结束时，俱乐部的银行账户里几乎没有钱了。这一消息曝光后，贝芙主动提出替弟弟还债，以免招致社区的抨击。她给了海伦1000美元，用来付清杂货商、面包师以及为俱乐部抽奖活动提供电视机的电器零售商的账单。账单总额为924美元。海伦把剩下的钱留作零用，并承诺日后偿还。过了一会儿，贝芙在当地的牛奶吧偶遇了海伦。海伦问她是否听到镇上有人在谈论拉塞尔的事。
Bev said she hadn't, to which Helen allegedly remarked. Isn't it good that nobody's talking? A few days after Russell allegedly took the money back, a few days after Russell allegedly left town, Helen pestered his brother Michael to clear up her yard using his front-end loader. Michael didn't like Helen, but agreed for the sake of his nieces and nephews. Helen watched him work from the back doorstep and gave him $10 when the job was done. Michael was unaware Russell had left town and Helen didn't mention it to him. Afterwards, she began returning tools and other items that Russell had borrowed from Michael and his other brother, Trevor.
贝芙说没有，海伦随即据称评论道：“没有人议论，这不是挺好的吗？”在拉塞尔据称拿走这笔钱几天后，在拉塞尔据称离开小镇几天后，海伦纠缠拉塞尔的兄弟迈克尔，让他用他的前置式装载机帮她清理院子。迈克尔不喜欢海伦，但为了侄女和侄子的份上还是答应了。海伦站在后门廊看着他干活，并在工作完成后给了他10美元。迈克尔并不知道拉塞尔已经离开了小镇，海伦也没有向他提及此事。此后，她开始归还拉塞尔向迈克尔和他的另一个兄弟特雷弗（Trevor）借来的工具和其他物品。
They were surprised when she told them that Russell wouldn't be coming back. Trevor later joked to his wife that he didn't think they'd be seeing Russell again because Helen had probably killed him. In the weeks following Russell's departure, Helen applied for maintenance and welfare for their children. She also sold some of his possessions and organized buyers for his farming machinery and vehicle. Russell's uncle, Billy Moeller, gave Helen $500 not to sell the machinery as Russell would need it when he came home. Russell also kept a bees as a side hobby and made a small amount of money as an apurist. Not wanting Russell's bee boxes to go to just anyone, Billy Moeller convinced his nephew Kenny to buy them. As he took the boxes away, Kenny noticed some had blood on them.
当她告诉他们拉塞尔不会回来时，他们都感到很惊讶。特雷弗后来开玩笑地对妻子说，他觉得他们不会再见到拉塞尔了，因为海伦可能已经把他杀了。在拉塞尔离开后的几周里，海伦为孩子们申请了生活费和福利。她还卖掉了一些他的物品，并为他的农用机械和车辆安排了买家。拉塞尔的叔叔比利·穆勒（Billy Moeller）给了海伦500美元，让她不要卖掉那些机械，因为拉塞尔回家时会用得上。拉塞尔还把养蜂作为副业，作为一名养蜂人赚了一小笔钱。为了不让拉塞尔的蜂箱随便落入他人之手，比利·穆勒说服他的侄子肯尼（Kenny）买下了它们。当他把蜂箱搬走时，肯尼注意到有些蜂箱上有血迹。
Helen said it was from a pig they had slaughtered a few weeks earlier. Kenny stored the boxes in a shed, unsure what else to do with them. Helen then traded in Russell's car for $350 and purchased the new one for $1,900. In late March, she met railway worker Mick Miller. Mick was new in town and within two weeks of meeting Helen, he had moved into the house she had shared with Russell on Ligar Street. Bev was shocked to hear about the relationship and confronted Helen. She asked whether Helen had heard any news from Russell. Helen claimed she had tried to report him missing but was told by the police officer on duty.
海伦说那是几周前他们宰杀的一头猪留下的。肯尼把蜂箱存放在一个棚子里，不知该拿它们怎么办。海伦随后以350美元的价格把拉塞尔的汽车折价换购，并以1900美元的价格买了一辆新车。3月下旬，她遇到了铁路工人米克·米勒（Mick Miller）。米克是镇上的新面孔，在认识海伦两周之内，他就搬进了她和拉塞尔在利加街共住的房子。贝芙听到这段恋情后大为震惊，并与海伦对质。她问海伦是否听到过拉塞尔的任何消息。海伦声称她曾试图报案他失踪，但被当值的警员告知：
He's over 21, he can look after himself and that he was probably with another woman. Helen assured Bev she would contact her police officer cousin to see if he could locate Russell. From then on, the two women had nothing to do with each other. Bev was sure that Russell would return for the stall gift in April. When he didn't show, she knew something wasn't right. She headed to the stall police station with her mother, Helen, to formally report Russell as a missing person. Senior Constable Richard Kennedy took the report. He was familiar with Russell Martin due to his run-ins with local authorities in the past.
他已经21岁了，能够照顾好自己，而且他可能和另一个女人在一起。海伦向贝芙保证，她会联系她的警察表弟，看看他能不能找到拉塞尔。从那以后，这两个女人便再无瓜葛。贝芙坚信拉塞尔会在4月份的斯塔勒赛跑时回来。当他没有出现时，她知道情况不对劲了。她带着母亲海伦前往斯塔勒警察局，正式将拉塞尔列为失踪人员报案。高级警员理查德·肯尼迪（Richard Kennedy）受理了这起报案。由于拉塞尔过去曾与地方当局发生过冲突，他对拉塞尔·马丁并不陌生。
Russell had been charged with drink driving, refusing to provide his details following an accident and the assault of two police officers. A gun-wielding Russell once threatened an officer after receiving a speeding ticket. On another occasion, he fired a shotgun into the air twice when the service at a drive-through bottle shop was too slow. Then there were the regular visits to the Martin household in relation to domestic violence. For two hours that afternoon, Constable Kennedy interviewed Helen Martin about her missing husband. She repeated a similar story to the one she had told Bev, adding that Russell appeared upset and might have been crying when he left. He wouldn't tell her where he was going, just that he had to leave. He encouraged her to sell everything, including his tools, to try and get herself out of debt.
拉塞尔曾被指控酒后驾车、在事故发生后拒绝提供个人信息以及袭警两名警察。手持枪械的拉塞尔曾因收到超速罚单而威胁一名警员。另一次，当汽车餐厅酒品店的服务太慢时，他向空中开了两枪猎枪。此外，还有关于马丁一家因家庭暴力而招致的定期造访。那天下午，肯尼迪警员对海伦·马丁进行了两个小时的关于她失踪丈夫的讯问。她重复了之前告诉贝芙的相似说法，并补充说拉塞尔离开时显得很沮丧，可能还哭过。他没有告诉她他要去哪里，只说他必须离开。他鼓励她卖掉一切，包括他的工具，以设法让自己摆脱债务。
Helen couldn't recall Russell's outfit that night, but saw him take a pair of jeans, trousers, a couple of shirts, underpants, and socks with him. He put the clothes in a paper bag, but left behind his toiletries and a new wristwatch. He was in a hurry and left within minutes. Helen watched the white panel van Russell had climbed into pull away from the house. She believed there might have been one or two more passengers inside. Two weeks later, Helen saw a similar white car parked outside her house. An unknown man was sitting inside. She first noticed him at 7.30pm.
海伦记不清拉塞尔那天晚上穿的衣服，但看到他带走了一条牛仔裤、长裤、几件衬衫、内裤和袜子。他把衣服装进一个纸袋里，却留下了洗漱用品和一块新手表。他当时很赶，在几分钟内就离开了。海伦看着拉塞尔爬上的那辆白色厢式货车从小屋前开走。她认为里面可能还有一两个乘客。两周后，海伦看到一辆类似的白色轿车停在她家门外。一个不知名的人坐在里面。她最初是在晚上7点30分注意到他的。
He remained there for the rest of the night. Helen was too frightened to go out and see who it was. Unable to sleep, at 2am she resorted to taking three sleeping tablets to bypass her anxiety. Helen told Constable Kennedy that there were several rumours circulating around the store regarding Russell's whereabouts. People had placed him all over Australia for various reasons. Some believed that Russell had been dealing drugs and ran off with his former lover. Others speculated that he was just over an hour's drive away in the regional city of Ballarat. This rumour placed Russell in Ballarat's psychiatric hospital, possibly because he had been treated there in the past for agrophobia.
他在那里呆了整晚。海伦吓得不敢出去看那是谁。由于无法入睡，她在凌晨2点时采取服用三片安眠药的方式来缓解焦虑。海伦告诉肯尼迪警员，斯塔勒当地流传着关于拉塞尔下落的几种谣言。由于各种原因，人们把他安插在澳大利亚的各地。有些人认为拉塞尔一直在贩毒，并与他的前情人私奔了。另一些人则推测他就在一个多小时车程外的区域城市巴拉腊特（Ballarat）。这个谣言把拉塞尔安置在巴拉腊特的精神病院里，可能是因为他过去曾因广场恐惧症在那里接受过治疗。
Investigators noted that Helen appeared at ease during questioning. She admitted that she had entered a new relationship with Mick Miller, but denied that they were living together. She said she wasn't sure what Russell would do if he came home and found them together, but conceded that he might try to injure her or Mick. Records confirmed that Mick hadn't arrived in stall until February 27, just over a month after Russell had disappeared. Due to this timing, investigators didn't consider him a suspect. Helen was evasive about the money stolen from the Glen Orkey Football Club. She told police that she had been left with many debts, which she was paying off in instalments. Her efforts to locate her husband had only involved a discussion about the situation with her cousin, who happened to be a police officer.
调查人员注意到海伦在接受讯问时显得很从容。她承认自己与米克·米勒开始了新的恋情，但否认他们同居。她表示不确定拉塞尔如果回家发现他们在一起会做出什么举动，但承认他可能会试图伤害她或米克。记录证实，米克直到2月27日才抵达斯塔勒，刚好在拉塞尔失踪一个月多一点之后。由于这个时间点，调查人员没有把他列为嫌疑人。海伦对格伦奥奇足球俱乐部被盗资金一事闪烁其词。她告诉警方，她留下了许多债务，她正在分期偿还。她寻找丈夫的努力仅限于与她的表弟（恰好是一名警察）讨论这种情况。
From Helen's point of view, there was nothing unusual about her husband disappearing for an extended period of time. Constable Kennedy didn't feel that Helen was being completely honest. He made inquiries with Russell's family, friends and neighbours to piece together his last known movements. He discovered that on Tuesday, January 18, Russell had visited his local doctor's office. Just over two months prior, Russell had broken his ankle after falling off the back of a horse. His check-up in mid-January confirmed the injury was healing well. Another appointment was made for Russell to attend a physiotherapy session two weeks later. The following day of Wednesday, January 19, Russell's neighbour, Charlie Stenhouse, visited the Martin family.
在海伦看来，她的丈夫长时间失踪并不是什么不寻常的事。肯尼迪警员觉得海伦并没有完全说实话。他向拉塞尔的家人、朋友和邻居进行了解，以拼凑他最后的已知行踪。他发现，在1月18日星期二，拉塞尔曾拜访过当地医生的诊所。就在两个多月前，拉塞尔从马背上摔下来导致脚踝骨折。他在1月中旬的复查证实伤势正在良好恢复中。另一项预约是让拉塞尔在两周后参加理疗。第二天，即1月19日星期三，拉塞尔的邻居查理·斯滕豪斯（Charlie Stenhouse）拜访了马丁一家。
Charlie told police that Russell was sick in bed at the time. He was wearing nothing but his underwear, while Helen applied ice packs to his head. Charlie described Russell as delirious. He was barely able to raise his head from his pillow. At one stage, Russell looked at his neighbour and said, Oh Charlie, before dropping his head back in exhaustion. Helen had told police that Russell left that night, but Charlie was certain Russell was in no state to leave home. Charlie visited the Martin house on the following Thursday, Friday and Saturday to check in on Russell.
查理告诉警方，拉塞尔当时生病躺在床上。他身上只穿着内衣，而海伦则在用冰袋敷他的头。查理形容拉塞尔神志不清。他几乎无法把头从枕头上抬起来。有一会儿，拉塞尔看着他的邻居说：“噢，查理。”然后筋疲力尽地把头垂了下去。海伦曾告诉警方拉塞尔当晚就离开了，但查理确信拉塞尔当时根本没有状态离开家。查理在随后的周四、周五和周六都拜访了马丁家，探望拉塞尔的情况。
Each time, Helen met him at the front door. She said that Russell was too sick to come out and that she didn't want to disturb him. On the fourth day, Helen broke down in tears and told Charlie, I've been telling you a lie about him being asleep. You'll hear about it from somebody else anyway, so I might as well tell you. He's cleared off and left me. Constable Kennedy felt that Charlie's recollections were authentic and believed he was the last person, other than Helen, to have seen Russell prior to his disappearance. The night that Russell had allegedly left home, Charlie's wife, Dory, heard a gunshot echo down the street.
每一次都是海伦在大门前接待他。她说拉塞尔病得太重不能出来，而且她不想打扰他。到了第四天，海伦崩溃大哭，对查理说：“关于他睡着的事，我一直都在对你撒谎。反正你迟早会从别人那里听到，所以不如我告诉你吧。他已经收拾东西一走了之，把我抛下了。”肯尼迪警员觉得查理的回忆是真实可信的，并认为除了海伦之外，他是见到拉塞尔失踪前的最后一个人。在拉塞尔据称离家出走的当晚，查理的妻子多莉（Dory）听到一声枪响在街上回荡。
She discussed the noise with another neighbour, Mavis, the following morning. Mavis told Dory that she had also heard the gunshot. But when police were making their inquiries into Russell Martin's disappearance, Mavis backpedalled and denied hearing the sound. She said she didn't want to get involved. Dory maintained she heard it. She also elaborated on the camping trip the Martin family had taken for new years. Dory and Charlie joined the Martins at the lake a few days into the holiday and recalled Russell and Helen having a huge fight. Russell stormed off down the beach and Helen followed him in tears.
第二天早上，她和另一个邻居玛维斯（Mavis）讨论了这个噪音。玛维斯告诉多莉，她也听到了枪声。但当警方对拉塞尔·马丁的失踪展开调查时，玛维斯却退缩并否认听到过这个声音。她说她不想卷入其中。多莉坚称她听到了。她还详细讲述了马丁一家为迎接新年而进行的露营旅行。多莉和查理在假期开始几天后加入了马丁一家在湖边的营地，并回忆说拉塞尔和海伦发生了一场大争吵。拉塞尔气冲冲地沿着海滩冲开，海伦则泪流满面地跟在后面。
They returned about half an hour later, but there was still tension between them. The following day, Dory and Helen went into the nearest town to have a beer. Helen was still upset, but didn't tell Dory what the argument was about. She said she wanted to leave Russell, but was afraid of what he would do. She also confided that Russell had been leaving the house late at night. She suspected he might have been having another affair. Dory couldn't remember if Russell was on crutches during the night. Dory couldn't remember if Russell was on crutches during the holiday.
他们大约半小时后回来了，但两人之间仍然弥漫着紧张气氛。第二天，多莉和海伦去了最近的镇上喝啤酒。海伦仍然很难过，但没有告诉多莉争吵的内容是什么。她说她想离开拉塞尔，但害怕他会做出什么举动。她还吐露说拉塞尔曾深夜离家。她怀疑他可能有外遇。多莉记不清拉塞尔在夜里是否拄着拐杖。多莉记不清拉塞尔在度假期间是否拄着拐杖。
She was aware that Helen left the campsite alone a few times to buy food from the nearest town. During the trip, Helen had also returned to stall twice on her own to collect mail and to pick up a mattress. There were reports that at around the time Russell went missing, Helen had been asking around for sleeping tablets. She hadn't done this before. Given the amount of time that had since passed, nobody could remember the exact date Helen was making these inquiries. When questioned, Helen told police she sought out the pills in the week after Russell went missing because she was unable to sleep. Several people also told police about the money that had gone missing from the Glen Orchie Football Club. Most believed Helen was responsible for the theft.
她知道海伦曾几次独自离开露营地去最近的镇上买食物。在旅行期间，海伦还曾两次独自返回斯塔勒取邮件和拿床垫。有报道称，大约在拉塞尔失踪期间，海伦曾四处打听安眠药。她以前从未这样做过。鉴于自那时起已经过去了很长时间，没有人能记住海伦进行这些打听的确切日期。当被讯问时，海伦告诉警方她在拉塞尔失踪后的一周内寻找这些药丸是因为她无法入眠。几个人还向警方讲述了格伦奥奇足球俱乐部资金失窃的事情。大多数人认为海伦是这起盗窃案的罪魁祸首。
Constable Kennedy viewed Helen with suspicion, describing her as, quote, a cunning type of person and a poor manager of money. Every person he spoke to agreed that if Helen had any idea that Russell was coming back, she would never have had another man in the house because Russell would kill them both. He contacted Helen's police officer cousin, Sergeant Royce Weir. She claimed to have spoken to her cousin after Russell went missing for the purpose of locating him. Sergeant Weir denied any such interaction took place. Russell's brother, Michael, had been paid by Helen to clean up her yard a few days after Russell went missing. Constable Kennedy wondered whether Helen had used this opportunity to remove or destroy evidence or to create a diversion or alibi. Police followed up with a friend of Russell's named Alan Frayne.
肯尼迪警员对海伦充满怀疑，形容她“引文：狡猾且不善理财”。他交谈过的每个人都一致认为，如果海伦有一点预感拉塞尔会回来，她绝对不敢让另一个男人进屋，因为拉塞尔会把他们两个都杀了。他联系了海伦的警察表弟罗伊斯·韦尔警长（Sergeant Royce Weir）。她声称自己在拉塞尔失踪后曾与表弟交谈过，目的是寻找他的下落。韦尔警长否认曾发生过这样的互动。拉塞尔的兄弟迈克尔曾在拉塞尔失踪几天后受海伦雇佣清理她的院子。肯尼迪警员纳闷海伦是否利用这个机会移走或摧毁证据，或是制造干扰或不在场证明。警方随后找到了拉塞尔的一位朋友阿兰·弗雷恩（Alan Frayne）。
One of the many rumours surrounding Russell's disappearance accused Alan of helping Russell leave stall by driving him into state. Alan admitted that he had travelled to Sydney around the time Russell went missing but denied taking his friend with him. There was also a rumour circulating that at around that time Alan had paid to have a concrete slab hastily installed on his property. Without seeking counsel approval, he had allegedly hired two local men to get the job done cheaply. The slab was laid down and a frame for a building was erected on top. Alan quickly realised that he'd gotten what he paid for when the slab had too many cracks to maintain any structural integrity. The building was abandoned and Townsville could gossip that Russell could be buried beneath the slab. Constable Kennedy sensed Alan Frayne knew more than he was willing to tell police.
围绕拉塞尔失踪的众多谣言之一指责阿兰通过开车把拉塞尔送出州来协助他离开斯塔勒。阿兰承认他在拉塞尔失踪前后曾去过悉尼，但否认带上了他的朋友。当时还流传着一个谣言，称阿兰大约在那时花钱在自己的物业上仓促铺设了一块混凝土板。在未经市议会批准的情况下，他据称雇佣了两个当地人以低成本完成了这项工作。水泥板铺好后，上面还搭建了一个建筑框架。阿兰很快意识到他是一分钱一分货，因为这块混凝土板裂缝太多，根本无法维持任何结构完整性。这栋建筑被废弃了，镇上的人们开始八卦说拉塞尔可能被埋在那块水泥板下面。肯尼迪警员感觉到阿兰·弗雷恩知道的远比他愿意向警方吐露的要多。
Many stall residents were certain Russell had stayed true to character and simply cleared off. Some believed Russell's psychiatric history was the reason for him going missing or that his mental health issues had led to self-harm. Russell's general practitioner described him as suffering from quote, mental hysteria. But his detailed psychiatric records were subject to patient confidentiality and couldn't be accessed. Others, including investigators, were more open to the possibility that Russell had met with foul play. During such deliberations, Helen Martin emerged as a person of interest. She had plenty of motives from having sustained years of abuse, gambling, infidelity and threats by her husband. It was an open secret around Town that the only way she could leave her marriage in a way that guaranteed her safety was if Russell was dead.
许多斯塔勒居民确信拉塞尔保持了本色，一走了之。有些人认为拉塞尔的精神病史是他失踪的原因，或者他的心理健康问题导致了自残。拉塞尔的全科医生形容他患有“引文：精神歇斯底里”。但他的详细精神病记录受到患者隐私权的保护，无法调阅。其他人，包括调查人员，则对拉塞尔遭遇不测的可能性持更开放的态度。在这样的审议过程中，海伦·马丁作为受关注人物浮出水面。她有着充分的动机，因为她长期遭受丈夫的虐待、赌博、不忠和威胁。镇上人尽皆知的是，她要想以确保自身安全的方式离开这段婚姻，唯一的可能就是拉塞尔已经死了。
However, it seemed unlikely Helen could orchestrate, carry out and cover up the murder alone. There were lingering suspicions around people like Alan Frayne and the timely installation of the concrete slab. But then, there were more damning allegations. Like many country towns at the time, there was significant friction between law enforcement and the local men doing it tough. Everyone knew that Russell clashed with the police more than most. However, nobody could recall a specific incident that would have been the catalyst for murder. Although Russell had a terrible rapport with local police, he was good mates with an officer named Peter Ivy. Ivy had just recently been stationed at the store.
然而，海伦似乎不太可能独自策划、实施并掩盖这起谋杀案。围绕阿兰·弗雷恩以及及时安装混凝土板等人，仍然存在挥之不去的怀疑。但随之而来的是更具杀伤力的指控。就像当时的许多乡村小镇一样，执法部门与在艰难环境中求生存的当地男子之间存在着严重的摩擦。所有人都知道，拉塞尔与警察的冲突比大多数人都要多。然而，没有人能回想起任何可能成为谋杀催化剂的具体事件。尽管拉塞尔与当地警察的关系糟糕透顶，但他与一名叫彼得·艾维（Peter Ivy）的警员是好哥们。艾维不久前刚被派驻到斯塔勒。
In his spare time, he coached and recruited players for the Glen Orkey Football Club. Despite their differences, Ivy and Russell bonded through the club and established a close friendship. They arrived at training together, went out drinking after games and socialised as a group with their wives. Rumours alleged that Ivy was having an affair with Russell's wife. Several people witnessed a fight between Russell and Ivy and speculated there was truth to the rumour. When asked about their reported affair by investigators, both Helen and Ivy were steadfast in their denial. Ivy also rejected claims that he and Russell had gotten into a fight. This was despite several witnesses, including Helen, stating otherwise.
在业余时间，他为格伦奥奇足球俱乐部执教并招募球员。尽管存在分歧，艾维和拉塞尔通过俱乐部建立起深厚的友谊。他们一起去训练，比赛后出去喝酒，并与各自的妻子作为群体一同社交。谣言称艾维与拉塞尔的妻子有染。几个人目睹了拉塞尔和艾维之间的争端，并推测传言并非空穴来风。当调查人员问及他们所谓的绯闻时，海伦和艾维都坚决予以否认。艾维也反驳了他和拉塞尔曾发生冲突的说法。尽管包括海伦在内的几位目击者言之凿凿地表示事实并非如此。
With no evidence that a crime had been committed, the investigation into Russell Martin's disappearance dwindled. Helen and Mick's relationship continued, with neither seemingly worried that Russell could return home at any minute. Helen sold Russell's saw bench, tractor and most of his possessions, using some of the proceeds to pay off debt collectors. Helen's brother, Philip Wilcock, told police that he avoided Helen as much as possible. He referred to her as a compulsive liar. Can't picture it? Well, you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ Crispy Chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. A year after her brother vanished without a trace, Bev Roberts hired a private investigator. It was a last ditch effort to get some answers.
由于没有证据表明发生了犯罪行为，对拉塞尔·马丁失踪案的调查逐渐减少。海伦和米克的恋情仍在继续，两人似乎都不担心拉塞尔会随时回家。海伦卖掉了拉塞尔的锯木台、拖拉机和大部分财产，用部分收益来偿还讨债人。海伦的兄弟菲利普·威尔考克（Philip Wilcock）告诉警方，他尽可能地躲着海伦。他称她为“强迫性说谎者”。想象不出来？现在你就可以去Tim's尝尝了。限时推出我们的全新烧烤脆鸡丰富碗和卷饼。在她弟弟毫无踪迹地消失一年后，贝芙·罗伯茨雇用了私家侦探。这是为了得到一些答案而做的最后绝望努力。
Her finances were limited. She couldn't afford much more than a basic search. The PI interviewed Helen Martin and did find some minor discrepancies and deviations from her earlier statements. But there wasn't enough to reinvigorate the investigation. Russell's family spent the following years chasing up alleged sightings. A man named Wayne Yoll told Russell's mother, Ellen, that he had seen Russell at a cafe in the Victorian town of Swan Hill. Wayne assured her that Russell was fine and told her not to worry. Later, Wayne admitted to concocting the sighting with a local publican because Ellen was coming in so often lamenting about her missing son. They had decided to make up the story in order to take the pressure off her.
她的资金有限。她承担不起比基本搜寻更多的费用。这位私家侦探采访了海伦·马丁，确实发现了一些与她早期陈述存在轻微出入和偏差的地方。但这些不足以重新激活调查。拉塞尔的家人在接下来的几年里一直在追踪据称的目击报告。一个名叫韦恩·约尔（Wayne Yoll）的男子告诉拉塞尔的母亲埃伦，他在维多利亚州斯旺希尔（Swan Hill）镇的一家咖啡馆里看到了拉塞尔。韦恩向她保证拉塞尔过得很好，并让她不要担心。后来，韦恩承认他和当地的一个酒馆老板捏造了这次目击，因为埃伦经常来诉苦并哀叹她失踪的儿子。他们决定编造这个故事是为了减轻她的压力。
Russell's uncle, Billy Moeller, travelled to different towns and questioned locals. Whenever he heard a rumor that Russell was spotted somewhere nearby, Billy would investigate the lead himself. It was rumoured that Billy was Russell's biological father. Whether or not it was true, the pair had shared a close, father-son-like bond since Russell was a boy. Billy kept searching for Russell until his death a couple years later. His nephew Kenny told investigators, any little thread Billy could grab, he always looked into it to see if there was any evidence anywhere. In 1979, Russell's mother passed away.
拉塞尔的叔叔比利·穆勒前往不同的城镇并向当地人盘问。每当他听到拉塞尔在某个附近地方被目击的谣言时，比利就会亲自去调查这条线索。有传言说比利是拉塞尔的亲生父亲。不管是不是真的，自拉塞尔还是个男孩起，两人就分享了一种亲密的、如父子般的纽带。比利一直在寻找拉塞尔，直到几年后他去世。他的侄子肯尼告诉调查人员：“比利能抓住的任何一根微小的线索，他总是会去查证，看看哪里是否有任何证据。”1979年，拉塞尔的母亲去世了。
Despite his difficult childhood, Russell loved his mum and was fiercely protective of her. Those who believed Russell was still alive were convinced he would return for the funeral. Yet, the service concluded and there was no sign of him. Even the most open-minded stall residents took Russell's absence as proof he was deceased. It was enough of a reason for the police to give the case one final look. Russell's missing person file had been taken over by Sergeant James Holcomb. On June 6, 1979, Sergeant Holcomb re-interviewed Helen Martin. He presented the discrepancies and inconsistencies in her statements
尽管有着艰难的童年，拉塞尔深爱着他的母亲，并且对她有着极强的保护欲。那些相信拉塞尔还活着的人确信他会回来参加葬礼。然而，追悼会结束了，却没有他的一丝踪迹。就连思想最开放的斯塔勒居民也将拉塞尔的缺席视为他已经去世的证据。这已经足够成为警方对该案进行最后一次审视的理由了。拉塞尔的失踪档案已由詹姆斯·霍尔科姆警长（Sergeant James Holcomb）接手。1979年6月6日，霍尔科姆警长重新讯问了海伦·马丁。他指出了她陈述中的差异和不一致之处，
and put forth a series of allegations that implicated her in Russell's death. It was a long and probing interview, but Sergeant Holcomb was unable to draw a definitive conclusion regarding Helen's possible involvement. Inquiries were made to government agencies, banks and utility providers, but there was no record of Russell Martin following his alleged departure from stall in 1977. Once again, the case went cold. His file was marked inactive, with the general consensus being that Russell was deceased, though the cause remained a point of contention.
并提出了一系列将她牵连进拉塞尔之死的指控。这是一次漫长而深入的讯问，但霍尔科姆警长未能就海伦可能参与其中得出明确的结论。相关部门向政府机构、银行和公用事业提供商进行了查询，但没有关于拉塞尔·马丁自1977年据称离开斯塔勒之后的任何记录。该案再次陷入僵局。他的档案被标记为未结案，普遍共识是拉塞尔已经死亡，尽管死因仍然是一个争论点。
Helen and Mick Miller broke up after several years due to infidelity on Mick's behalf. Soon after, Helen started a relationship with a local slaughterman named Charles Smith. Smith had a criminal history that included assault of a police officer's son and carnal knowledge of a girl between 10 and 16 years of age. Smith was married when he met Helen, but left his wife to move in with Helen and her four children at their home on Ligar Street. The couple married in September 1983, and Helen took on her husband's surname. 2001 marked 24 years since Russell went missing.
海伦和米克·米勒由于米克的不忠，在几年后分手了。不久之后，海伦与当地一名叫查尔斯·史密斯（Charles Smith）的屠夫开始了恋情。史密斯有犯罪记录，包括袭击警察的儿子以及与一名10岁至16岁女孩发生肉体关系。史密斯在遇到海伦时已经结婚，但他离开妻子搬去和海伦以及她的四个孩子一起住在利加街的家中。两人于1983年9月结婚，海伦随了丈夫的姓氏。2001年标志着拉塞尔失踪24周年。
It was announced that a coronial inquest would be conducted the following year to determine what likely happened to Russell. In the lead-up, detectives made further inquiries and re-interviewed those connected to the case. A couple of Russell's friends and acquaintances told a story about a local panel-beater named Bill Joyner, who often repaired damaged police vehicles. Around the time of Russell's disappearance, a police officer allegedly visited Bill in the middle of the night. He insisted that a repair be done urgently and discreetly. There was a large dent in the bonnet of the officer's police car that looked like it could have been made by a kangaroo,
据宣布，将于次年举行验尸官研讯，以确定拉塞尔可能遭遇了什么。在此之前，侦探们进行了进一步的调查，并重新讯问了与此案相关的人。拉塞尔的几个朋友和熟人讲了一个关于当地面板修理工比尔·乔伊纳（Bill Joyner）的故事，他经常修理受损的警车。在拉塞尔失踪前后，一名警察据称在半夜拜访了比尔。他坚持要求紧急且低调地进行修理。那辆警车发动机罩上有一个很大的凹痕，看起来可能像是袋鼠撞出来的，
but that explanation didn't account for the secrecy of the job. One man swore that it had been a human-shaped dent. By the time detectives were informed of this alleged incident, Bill Joyner was deceased and could not be called upon to confirm the incident. Joyner was deceased and could not be called upon to confirm or deny. Stories also arose that Russell had attended a wild party on the night of his disappearance. Police officer Peter Ivy was also said to have been at the party. At one stage, both men got into a massive fight.
但这种解释无法说明这项工作的神秘性。其中一个人发誓说，那是一个人形形状的凹痕。等到侦探们被告知这起所谓的事件时，比尔·乔伊纳已经去世，无法被传唤来确认这一事件。乔伊纳已经去世，无法被传唤来确认或否认。也有故事称，拉塞尔在他失踪的那天晚上参加了一个狂欢派对。警员彼得·艾维据说也出席了派对。一度，这两人爆发了一场激烈的打斗。
Russell left for a brief period, then returned with a knife. He threw it in the sink and declared that a local man named Danny Marks, quote, wouldn't be using that again. However, it seemed like these were misremembered events. The party in question was not held the night Russell disappeared. It was held to mark the end of the football season, which occurred months prior. Danny Marks, who Russell had mentioned in relation to the knife, had no recollection of the incident. Russell's neighbour, Charlie Stenhouse, had seen Russell the day of his disappearance bedridden, exhausted and in ill health.
罗素离开了一小会儿，随后拿着一把刀回来。他把它扔进水槽里，声称当地有个叫丹尼·马克斯的人，原话是，“不会再用那个了”。然而，这些似乎都是记忆出现偏差的事情。当事人举办派对的那晚并不是罗素失踪的那晚。那场派对是为了庆祝足球赛季结束，而这几个月前就已经结束了。罗素在提到那把刀时说到的丹尼·马克斯，对这起事件毫无记忆。罗素的邻居查理·斯坦豪斯在罗素失踪当天看到他卧床不起、精疲力竭且身体状况不佳。
Charlie had since passed away, but his recollections did not support the theory that Russell was out partying. Detectives interviewed Billy Muller's nephew Kenny, who had bought Russell's B-Boxes from Helen in 1977. He had noticed there was blood on them. Helen had told him the source was a slaughtered pig. On January 30, 2001, police went to Kenny's house to get the boxes from his shed, where they had been left untouched for over two decades. Several of the boxes were engraved with the number M-437, which was Russell's beekeeping license number. Others had his name written on them in texta.
查理在此之后已经去世，但他的回忆并不支持罗素当时外出聚会的说法。侦探们采访了比利·穆勒的侄子肯尼，他在1977年从海伦那里买下了罗素的蜂箱。他注意到上面有血迹。海伦告诉他血源是一头被宰杀的猪。2001年1月30日，警察前往肯尼的房子，从他的棚子里取回了这些蜂箱，这些蜂箱在那里被放置了二十多年无人动过。其中几个蜂箱上刻有编号M-437，这是罗素的养蜂执照号码。其他箱子上则用记号笔写着他的名字。
The blood-stained boxes were nowhere to be found. There were two boxes and some frames marked with a red substance, but Kenny didn't believe these were the ones that had caught his attention in 1977. Testing confirmed the red substance wasn't blood. Detective Mark McCann had since taken over Russell Martin's case as the lead investigator. On March 8, 2001, he re-interviewed Helen Martin, now Helen Smith. He addressed the inconsistencies in her statements. She had told one officer that Russell had left $100 on the bench before he left,
那些带有血迹的蜂箱无影无踪。有两个箱子和一些架子上标记着一种红色物质，但肯尼不认为这就是1977年引起他注意的那几个。经检测证实，这种红色物质并不是血。侦探马克·麦坎此后接手了罗素·马丁的案件，成为首席调查员。2001年3月8日，他重新盘问了海伦·马丁（现在叫海伦·史密斯）。他指出了她供述中的矛盾之处。她曾对一名警官说，罗素离开前在长凳上留下了100美元，
but had denied this to another. Helen had talked about being deep in debt, yet had purchased a new vehicle several weeks after Russell went missing. She also claimed that two males from out of town had shown up at her house after Russell left, wanting to purchase drugs. Detective McCann deemed this unlikely, as no one throughout the 24-year investigation had ever mentioned that Russell used drugs, other than prescription medication. On March 14, police re-interviewed Russell's friend, Alan Frame, about the hastily laid concrete slab on his property. Alan continued to deny any knowledge of Russell's disappearance, but officers felt he was hiding something. A week later, they arrived at Alan's property with scientists from Monash University. A geoscope search was carried out on the slab.
但对另一名警官却予以否认。海伦曾谈到自己身负重债，却在罗素失踪几周后购买了一辆新车。她还声称，罗素离开后，有两个外地男子来到她家，想要购买毒品。侦探麦坎认为这不太可能，因为在长达24年的调查中，除了处方药之外，没有人提到过罗素吸毒。3月14日，警方重新盘问了罗素的朋友阿兰·弗雷姆，关于他房产上那块仓促铺设的混凝土板。阿兰继续否认自己知道罗素失踪的任何事情，但警官们觉得他在隐瞒什么。一周后，他们带着莫纳什大学的科学家来到了阿兰的房产。他们对这块混凝土板进行了地质探测扫描。
It came up with a negative result, meaning there was no justification to dig it up. The coroner's inquest into Russell Martin's disappearance began in May 2002. By this time, his four adult children had varying levels of interest in finding out what happened to their father. The eldest, Lee, had just started grade six when her dad went missing. She had been away at school camp at the time. When she returned home, Helen had told her that Russell was on holiday. Lee continually asked her mother where her father was and when he was coming back, but Helen never spoke about it. Later in life, Lee had come to the conclusion that Russell was still alive.
结果呈阴性，这意味着没有理由将其挖开。关于罗素·马丁失踪案的验尸官研讯于2002年5月开始。此时，他的四个成年子女对于弄清他们父亲身上发生了什么有着不同程度的关注。大女儿莉莉在她的爸爸失踪时刚刚上六年级。当时她正外出参加学校夏令营。当她回家时，海伦告诉她罗素去度假了。莉莉不断地问她母亲父亲在哪里、什么时候回来，但海伦从不谈论此事。晚年时，莉莉得出结论认为罗素仍然活着。
When asked how her mother felt about him leaving, Lee said, she was probably relieved because dad used to hit her. The second eldest, Kelly, was seven at the time and didn't remember Russell. All she knew of him was that her mother said he was an asshole. Kelly was convinced her father was most likely dead and she believed at the rumors around town that the local police had something to do with it. Stephen, who was six when his dad went missing, said that Helen never talked about Russell. Stephen said, she might know something, but I know there's a lot more people who know a hell of a lot more. The youngest, Paul, couldn't remember anything about his dad.
当被问及母亲对他的离开作何感想时，莉莉说，她可能松了一口气，因为爸爸以前经常打她。次子凯利当时七岁，对罗素没有印象。他对罗素的全部了解就是母亲说他是个混蛋。凯利确信他的父亲多半已经死了，并且他相信镇上的传言，即当地警方与此事脱不了干系。斯蒂芬在父亲失踪时六岁，他说海伦从不谈论罗素。斯蒂芬说，她可能知道些什么，但我知道还有更多的人知道得远比这多得多。最小的儿子保罗对他的爸爸没有任何记忆。
He too had heard people say that the police had given his father a hiding and that they had thrown his body down a mine shaft. The location of stall on the edge of the Victorian Goldfields meant there were hundreds of disused mineshafts nearby. Locals often used them to illegally dump rubbish and other refuse. There were rumors that the local police disposed of old vehicle number plates in the mines rather than do the paperwork to deregister them correctly. By the time of the inquest, it had been 25 years since Russell Martin vanished. Memories had faded. Witnesses provided contrasting recollections of the same events. Some referenced the gossip as fact, while others just wanted to inject themselves into the dramatic mystery.
他也听人说过，警察把他的父亲痛打了一顿，并把他的尸体扔进了一个矿井里。由于斯托尔位于维多利亚金矿区的边缘，这意味着附近有数百个废弃的矿井。当地人经常用它们来非法倾倒垃圾和其他废弃物。有传言称，当地警方将旧车牌扔进矿井里，而不是去做正规注销所需的文书工作。到研讯之时，罗素·马丁失踪已经25年了。记忆已经模糊。证人们对同一事件提供了截然不同的回忆。有些人将八卦当作事实引用，而另一些人只是想把自己卷入到这出戏剧性的谜团中。
Key players wanted to minimise the role they played. Kenny Moeller was grilled about the blood he saw on Russell's bee boxes. Some believed the story was made up or exaggerated to place suspicion on Helen. Helen's ex-boyfriend, Mick Miller, testified that Helen never spoke about Russell, nor did her children. Helen didn't fear his possible return either, as though certain he was gone for good. Mick was aware that Russell was violent and possessive, but it didn't bother him. He thought he could hold his own if Russell reappeared. Russell's son, Stephen, said that the court ought to hear from local police officer Murray Emerson.
关键人物试图尽量减少他们所扮演的角色。肯尼·莫勒就被他看到的罗素蜂箱上的血迹一事接受了盘问。一些人认为这个故事是捏造的或夸大其词的，目的是将怀疑引向海伦。海伦的前男友米克·米勒作证说，海伦从未谈论过罗素，她的孩子们也没有。海伦也不害怕他可能会回来，仿佛确信他已经永远离开了一样。米克知道罗素既暴力又占有欲强，但这并不困扰他。他认为如果罗素再次出现，他自己能够应付。罗素的儿子斯蒂芬说，法庭应该听听当地警官默里·爱默生的说法。
Emerson was known to have had bad blood with Russell. According to Stephen, it was Emerson who had taken his police wagon to get fixed at Panel Beta Bill Joiner's place. From what Stephen had heard, there had been blood all over the front of the vehicle as well as the large dent. Given that Helen had previously denied that the vehicle she saw Russell get into was a police car, Stephen was asked what he thought the connection was between the police wagon and his father's disappearance. He responded, I don't know. It's for use to find out.
众所周知，爱默生与罗素有宿怨。据斯蒂芬所说，正是爱默生把他的警车开到面板贝塔比利·乔纳的地方去修理。据斯蒂芬所听说的，汽车车头以及那个大凹陷上全都是血。鉴于海伦此前曾否认她看到罗素上的车是一辆警车，斯蒂芬被问及他认为警车与他父亲的失踪之间有什么联系。他回答说，我不知道。这得由你们去查明。
Sergeant James Holcomb took over Russell's missing person file in 1978. During the inquest, it was revealed that he had been safekeeping taped conversations that would provide useful information if Russell's body was ever found. The tapes included a recorded interview with Russell's former neighbour, Charlie Stanhouse. The other was a covertly recorded discussion with Helen. Russell's brother, Michael, voiced his belief that Helen was participating in several affairs at the time of Russell's disappearance. The first allegedly involved Billy Moeller, Russell's uncle, and rumoured biological father. Billy died prior to the inquest. The other alleged affair was Russell's former football coach, local police officer Peter Ivy.
詹姆斯·霍尔科姆警长于1978年接手了罗素的失踪人口档案。在研讯期间，据透露，他一直妥善保管着录音磁带，如果罗素的尸体被找到，这些磁带将提供有用的信息。磁带包括对罗素前邻居查理·斯坦豪斯的录音采访。另一份是秘密录下的与海伦的对话。罗素的兄弟迈克尔表达了他的信念，即海伦在罗素失踪期间参与了几段婚外情。据称第一段涉及罗素的叔叔、传闻中的生父比利·莫勒。比利在研讯前就已经去世了。另一段据称的婚外情对象是罗素的前足球教练、当地警官彼得·伊维。
Ivy denied ever having a sexual relationship with Helen, stating, That amazes me that anyone's ever said that. I can't think of any situation that I've ever been in where someone would think something like that. Ivy said his memories of Russell were limited, and that he couldn't recall whether he spoke to Helen about his disappearance. He also claimed not to know whether there was any domestic violence in their marriage. But when pushed, he said, Well, from my recollection, they did have a fiery type of marriage. They were a fiery couple.
伊维否认曾与海伦有过性关系，并表示：“这让我感到震惊，居然有人会说出这种话。我想象不出我曾身处任何会让别人产生这种想法的境地。”伊维说他对罗素的记忆很有限，并且不记得自己是否曾向海伦提及他的失踪。他还声称不知道他们的婚姻中是否存在家庭暴力。但在追问之下，他说道：“嗯，据我回忆，他们确实有过一段激烈的婚姻。他们是一对火爆的夫妻。”
It was Russell's sister Bev and mother Ellen who had filed the official missing persons report to senior constable Kennedy in 1977. A second missing persons report was tended in court that appeared to have been filed later by Helen and signed by Peter Ivy. Ivy said he didn't take the report, but couldn't explain why his name was on it. Helen was spoken to after Bev and Ellen made their initial report. No one was able to explain to the court why this second report was signed with Peter Ivy's name. Russell's youngest son, Paul, testified that he had recently been approached by a man who claimed to know where his father's body was. The man had taken him to the location the night before, but Paul had been unable to find it when he returned to the side on his own in the morning.
正是罗素的姐姐贝夫和母亲埃伦在1977年向资深警员肯尼迪提交了正式的失踪人口报告。法庭上出示了一份第二份失踪人口报告，这份报告似乎是后来由海伦提交并由彼得·伊维签署的。伊维说他没有受理该报告，但无法解释为什么上面会有他的名字。在贝夫和埃伦提交最初的报告后，警方找海伦谈过话。没有人能向法庭解释为什么这份第二份报告上会签署彼得·伊维的名字。罗素的小儿子保罗作证说，他最近被一个声称知道他父亲尸体在哪里的男人接近了。那个男人在前一天晚上带他去了那个地点，但当保罗早上独自一人返回该地点时，他没能找到。
He refused to name the man as he didn't want to get him in trouble. Paul said he would show the police the location once he had verified it during the daylight. Based on this tip-off, the court heard that members of the state emergency service attended an area at Green Lake. The off-stream reservoir and recreational area was 55 kilometres northwest of the store. There, they located two sunken areas in the ground. They dug approximately one foot deep, but found no indication that anything was buried there. Over the years, suspicion had also been cast on Helen's new husband, Charles Smith. Charles testified that sitting in court was the first time he had ever heard that anyone thought Helen had something to do with it.
他拒绝说出这个男人的名字，因为他不想给他惹麻烦。保罗说，一旦他在白天核实了地点，他就会把位置指给警察看。根据这条线索，法庭得知州紧急服务部门的人员前往了绿湖附近的一个地区。这个离槽水库和娱乐区位于斯托尔西北55公里处。在那里，他们找到了地面上的两个下沉区域。他们向下挖了大约一英尺深，但没有发现任何东西被埋在那里的迹象。这些年来，海伦的新丈夫查尔斯·史密斯也受到了怀疑。查尔斯作证说，坐在法庭里是他第一次听说有人认为海伦与此事有关。
He said he'd heard all kinds of rumours over the years, but never had any interest in delving into them further. He denied having ever met Russell and asserted that he had met Helen for the first time years after her husband's disappearance. This contradicted a statement made by Charles and Russell's mutual friend, Alan Frame. Alan said the men lived close to one another, moved in the same social circles, and had known each other from the pub. He considered it unlikely that they had never crossed paths. Helen appeared on the stand. She was asked whether she was concerned that Russell might return home to find she had moved on with another man. Helen responded,
他说他这些年来听过各种各样的传言，但从没有兴趣去进一步深究。他否认自己曾见过罗素，并坚称他在海伦丈夫失踪多年后才第一次见到海伦。这与查尔斯和罗素的共同朋友阿兰·弗雷姆的陈述相矛盾。阿兰说，这两个男人住得很近，在同一个社交圈活动，并且在酒吧里就认识对方。他认为他们从未擦肩而过的可能性微乎其微。海伦出庭作证。她被问及是否担心罗素可能会回家发现她已经和另一个男人开始了新生活。海伦回答说，
I was always concerned about him returning, yes, but I had to live my own life too. She denied having any involvement in or knowledge of any foul play against Russell. She said that she had provided police with the number plate details of the car she thought Russell had left in. Officers had no record of this information and suspected she was lying. Detective Mark McCann, who had taken over as lead detective on the case, told the court, I believe that Russell Martin has been murdered and I further believe that Helen Smith has more knowledge of it than she has led the court to believe thus far. On July 5 2002, Coroner Timothy McDonald handed down his findings. He deemed the evidence given by Helen, her husband Charles Smith, and former stall police officer Peter Ivey to be unconvincing and evasive.
“我一直担心他会回来，是的，但我也不得不过我自己的生活。”她否认自己参与或知晓针对罗素的任何不法行为。她说她已经向警方提供了她认为罗素离开时所坐的那辆车的车牌详情。警官们没有这条信息的记录，并怀疑她在撒谎。作为该案首席侦探的侦探马克·麦坎对法庭表示：“我相信罗素·马丁已经被谋杀，并且我进一步相信，海伦·史密斯对该案的了解比她目前向法庭透露的要多。”2002年7月5日，验尸官蒂莫西·麦克唐纳宣布了他的调查结果。他认为海伦、她的丈夫查尔斯·史密斯以及前斯托尔警官彼得·伊维的证词缺乏说服力且闪烁其词。
Quote, I am satisfied that the witness Peter Ivey was not a frank, open, or truthful witness in the evidence that he gave to the court. I did not accept that a person who was a police officer and who played sport with Russell Martin and drove his truck to assist him when he had a broken ankle would have such little memory of the details surrounding Martin going missing. He was an unreliable witness. Further, I am satisfied that Charles Smith knows more of the circumstances surrounding the disappearance of Russell Martin than what he has told investigators in this court. He was an evasive and vague witness who was hard to pin down to give clear and definitive evidence. Smith has indicated to investigators that he had little or no knowledge of Russell Martin at the time of his disappearance. He says he may have met him at a hotel at some time, but cannot recall this.
原话是，“我确信证人彼得·伊维在向法庭提供的证词中不是一个坦率、公开或真实的证人。我不接受一个曾担任警官、和罗素·马丁一起进行体育运动并在他脚踝骨折时开车去协助他的这样一个对马丁失踪的细节几乎毫无记忆的人。他是一个不可靠的证人。此外，我确信查尔斯·史密斯对罗素·马丁失踪的周围情况的了解比他在本法庭上向调查人员所说的要多。他是一个闪烁其词、含糊不清的证人，很难让他给出清晰明确的证词。史密斯曾向调查人员表示，他在罗素·马丁失踪时对其实际上一无所知或知之甚少。他说他可能曾在某个时候在酒店见过他，但对此记不清了。”
This is inconsistent with the evidence of Alan Frayne. Because of the unreliability of Smith's evidence, I am unable to accept his assertion that he was not known to Helen Martin prior to the 20th of January 1977. Helen Smith has also been vague, unclear, and misleading in what she has told different people about the circumstances of her husband's disappearance. What I am satisfied of is that the behavior of Helen Martin, very shortly after she says her husband left home, is consistent with her knowing that he would never return. Other than saying that her husband told her he would not be returning, there is no evidence before this inquest for the court to find that it would be reasonable for Helen Martin to believe that this would be the case. Reasons for reaching this conclusion are the evidence before the court is that Russell Martin loved his children. He had strong family and other ties in store. Whenever he had left the matrimonial home on other occasions, he had always returned.
这与阿兰·弗雷姆的证词不一致。由于史密斯证词的不可靠性，我无法接受他关于自己在1977年1月20日之前不认识海伦·马丁的断言。海伦·史密斯在向不同的人讲述她丈夫失踪的情况时，也一直含糊不清、模棱两可且具有误导性。我所确信的是，海伦·马丁在她声称丈夫离开家后不久的行为，与她知道他绝不会回来的情况是一致的。除了说她的丈夫告诉她他不会回来之外，本次研讯中没有任何证据能让法庭认定海伦·马丁认为会是这种情况是合理的。得出这一结论的理由是，法庭掌握的证据表明罗素·马丁深爱他的孩子。他在斯托尔拥有牢固的家庭和其他纽带。每当他在其他场合离开婚姻住所时，他总是会回来的。
Witnesses have given evidence that he would not leave store without ever having some contact with the people he loved. There is no reasonable explanation before the court as to why he would want to leave store permanently. Coroner McDonald believed the information provided by Russell's now deceased neighbour, Charlie Stanhouse. Charlie said he had visited the Martin House on Wednesday, January 19 and saw Russell bedridden and in a delirious state. Coroner McDonald quote, I am satisfied that Helen Smith has not disclosed the true circumstances surrounding the disappearance of her husband to the court. Further, I'm satisfied that she possesses information that is likely to establish such circumstances. After taking into account all of the evidence before the court,
证人们作证说，他绝不会在没有与他所爱的人进行某种联系的情况下离开斯托尔。法庭面前没有任何合理的解释能够说明他为什么要永久离开斯托尔。麦克唐纳验尸官相信了罗素现已去世的邻居查理·斯坦豪斯提供的信息。查理说他曾在1月19日星期三访问过马丁家，并看到罗素卧床不起且处于神志不清的状态。麦克唐纳验尸官原话：“我确信海伦·史密斯没有向法庭透露她丈夫失踪的真实情况。此外，我确信她掌握着很可能证实这种真实情况的信息。”在考虑了法庭上的所有证据之后，
I'm satisfied that the disappearance of Russell Martin on or about the 20th of January 1977 was associated with suspicious circumstances and that he died on or about that date from causes that were not natural. Despite these findings, there was no new information that warranted Russell's case being reinvestigated and no arrests were made. Russell's sister Bev was pleased with the coroner's findings but disappointed that no further inquiries would take place. She provided a DNA sample to the Victorian Institute of Forensic Medicine to be compared with their collection of unidentified human remains. There wasn't a match. She tried every available avenue to have Russell's case heard or reinvestigated and meticulously noted, filed and reported every new lead that came her way. A person can only apply to the coroner to have the case reopened if there is substantial new information available.
我确信罗素·马丁在1977年1月20日左右的失踪与可疑情况有关，并且他在该日或前后死于非自然原因。尽管有这些发现，但并没有出现足以让罗素的案件被重新调查的新信息，也没有人被捕。罗素的姐姐贝夫对验尸官的调查结果感到满意，但对不会进行进一步调查感到失望。她向维多利亚法医学研究所提供了DNA样本，以便与他们的未名人类遗骸收藏进行比对。没有找到匹配的。她尝试了所有可用的途径来让罗素的案件得到审理或重新调查，并一丝不苟地记录、存档和举报了她遇到的每一个新线索。一个人只有在有大量新信息可用的情况下，才能向验尸官申请重审此案。
Bev has tried several times over the years to have Russell's case reopened. Recently, a local man came forward claiming to have seen Russell put into a police van by a known local officer, never to be seen again. However, this claim didn't match with the timing of information known to be true, such as Russell's last doctor's appointment. In March 2020, Bev received a letter from the coroner's court saying they couldn't take the matter any further and that, quote, These inquiries have now been exhausted and therefore the police investigation is currently considered inactive. Most people want Bev to move on, due in part to Russell's history of violence and crime. Some may think Russell deserved his outcome, whatever it may have been. Bev accepts that her brother was no angel, but believes that justice should prevail.
这些年来，贝夫曾多次试图让罗素的案件重新开庭。最近，当地一名男子站出来声称，曾看到罗素被一名当地的知名警官推上一辆警车，从此再也没有露面。然而，这一说法与已知真实信息的时机不符，例如罗素最近一次看医生的预约。2020年3月，贝夫收到验尸官法院的一封信，称他们无法将此事进一步推进，并且原话是，“这些调查现已用尽，因此警方目前认为该调查处于不活跃状态。”大多数人都希望贝夫向前看，部分原因是因为罗素有暴力和犯罪的历史。有些人可能认为罗素无论遭遇了什么都是罪有应得。贝夫承认她的弟弟并非天使，但她坚信正义应当战胜一切。
Judging victims of crime based on their character and only investigating the murders of those who are deemed to good is not what the law is about. Bev is getting on in years and her health is beginning to fail her. Russell's brothers have passed away and she feels that she is the only one left who cares that he's gone. All she wants before she joins her brothers is to get some sort of resolution. For over two decades, Bev has written to police chiefs, lawyers, magistrates, coroners and to the missing persons advocacy network. She has begged them all for the same thing. Please find out what happened to my brother, Russell. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
根据犯罪受害者的品格来对他们进行评判，并且只调查那些被认为足够好的人的谋杀案，这并非法律的初衷。贝夫已经上了年纪，她的健康状况也开始恶化。罗素的兄弟们已经去世，她觉得她是唯一一个还在乎他已经离去的人。在她与她的兄弟们团聚之前，她所渴望的只是获得某种结果。二十多年来，贝夫一直写信给警察局长、律师、地方法官、验尸官以及失踪人口倡导网络。她向他们所有人乞求同一件事。请查明我弟弟罗素身上究竟发生了什么。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。